bonjour Hervé Marseille merci beaucoup
d'être notre invité politique ce matin
sénateur de chaîne président du groupe
Union centriste au Sénat et président de
l'udei en étant ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représentée par Fabrice wesser Redon
bonjour Fabrice bonjour Hervé Marseille
bonjour des journaux du groupe Ebra les
journaux régionaux de l'Est de la France
Fabrice on va évidemment longuement
parler de la réforme de retraite le
Sénat donc approuvé le texte dans la
nuit de samedi à dimanche le
gouvernement peut vous dire merci
non c'est le parlementarisme et le
vicamerisme qui sortent grandit de
j'allais dire de ce vote sur le fond et
sur la forme vous êtes satisfait de la
manière dont cette réforme est passée au
Sénat
satisfait oui parce que on a fait notre
métier on a accompli notre mission
c'est-à-dire on a fait ce que doit faire
un parlement une assemblée parlementaire
on a été au bout du texte maintenant ça
paraît surprenant d'aller au bout d'un
texte mais je ne suis pas satisfait des
conditions dans lesquelles ça c'est fait
c'était la question
pourquoi parce que on est passé d'une
gauche
sénatoriale qui était
républicaine qui était dans le dialogue
qui est donné un caractère singulier à
ce qui se passait au Sénat à une gauche
qui est
devenu la version le prolongement de la
nupesse au Sénat d'ailleurs
disait le Sénat ça doit pas être ni une
barricade ni un miroir je crois que la
volonté de la gauche sénatoriale c'était
de devenir une barricade d'empêcher
d'empêcher l'ont dit clairement le vote
de ce texte c'est une
mutation de la façon de travailler au
Sénat et ça veut dire qu'il y aura un
avant et un après pour le Sénat qui
voudra dire quoi pour la suite pour les
hôtesses ça dépendra du comportement de
de à l'avenir de la gauche regardez
quant à la dernière minute c'est quand
même symptomatique un peu plus ilanime
la gauche par la loi de Monsieur canner
demande qu'on vérifie le Corum
le Corum à minuit c'est je veux dire ça
un caractère comment dire un peu plus
ilanime à la dernière minute on se
croirait dans un une réunion de
copropriété ou il y a trois
copropriétaires qui essaient de bloquer
le vote
de je ne sais quoi enfin je veux dire on
voit bien que il y a un état d'esprit
qui a changé la gauche a abîmé le Sénat
faire et c'est-à-dire bloqué or le rôle
d'un parlement c'est c'est pas de
bloquer on a eu à l'Assemblée nationale
puis au Sénat la minorité qui bloquait
les institutions comment on fait pour
travailler en démocratie il y a des
institutions
c'est pas de transmettre à la rue quel
que soit d'ailleurs la force de
l'expression de la rue ou au tribunaux
le Conseil constitutionnel est une
juridiction c'est la plus haute le soin
de faire les choix politiques
c'est la même chose non c'est pas la
même chose dans l'expression c'est moins
tonitruant il y a pas eu les insultes il
y a pas eu j'allais dire les
comportements inapproprié qu'on a vu à
l'Assemblée mais il y a une mutation
dans la façon de faire parce que la
gauche elle employé les armes
parlementaires à sa disposition comme là
comme la majorité employé l'article 38
comme le gouvernement employé le vote
bloqué pourquoi lui reprocher ce que
tout le monde a fait finalement
approcher la façon dont ils ont
travaillé à partir des institutions
d'ailleurs eux ils considèrent que c'est
légitime et quand nous nous utilisons la
Constitution ils disent ah non non mais
ça ça va pas du tout et c'est pas normal
on va revenir sur le vote il y a 57
sénateurs dans le groupe Union Centris
seul 37 ont voté la réforme si son votés
contre 14 se sont abstenus c'est un
problème non pas du tout moi j'ai un
groupe où il y a liberté de vote
à tout moment les sénateurs du groupe
votent en fonction de leur conviction
leur conscience au moment des
présidentielles beaucoup d'entre eux ont
voté Emmanuel Macron dès le premier tour
bon voilà ils ont leur liberté
qui n'ont pas adopté ce texte sur les 57
parce que certains avaient des des
comment dire des convictions par rapport
à ce qui se passait dans leur
département ou par rapport au texte j'ai
par exemple un sénateur qui qui n'a pas
voté le texte parce qu'il considérait
qu'il n'allait pas assez loin il y a
toutes sortes de convictions qui
s'expriment derrière au-delà des 64 j'ai
un certain nombre de sénateurs qui
disent mais enfin tout ça pour ça quoi
je veux dire il y a déficit on nous dit
il faut une réforme pour résorber le
déficit bon fallait peut-être aller un
petit peu plus loin parce que finalement
on s'aperçoit que cette réforme elle va
encore être temporaire elle est
nécessaire mais temporaire c'est aussi
votre avis il aurait fallu aller plus
loin non je pense qu'elle est au départ
elle est un peu équilibrée maintenant on
va voir ce que ça va donner en CMP
est-ce qu'Emmanuel Macron n'a pas réussi
durablement à diviser y compris dans
votre camp
je crois que c'est la France qui est
divisée regardez les résultats du vote
de l'élection législative ce qui fait
que l'Assemblée nationale est
difficilement gouvernable ce sont les
Français qui qui sont de plus en plus
divisés après comment on peut faire pour
les rassembler ça c'est c'est au
président de la République de prendre
des études c'est pour ça que je cite
Emmanuel Macron qui est quand même
l'homme de la recomposition politique en
tout cas c'est ce qu'il souhaite oui
mais l'assemblée escalée et donc à
l'Assemblée il faudrait faire des
élections en législatives à nouveau je
suis pas totalement sûr que ça soit
pertinent par les temps qui courent
certains demandent une
dissolutions législatives le
rassemblement national en ferait ses
choix donc non on va revenir sur les
fractures et sur la contestation mais
pour rester sur le fond du texte est-ce
que ce texte correspond à ce que vous
vouliez ou est-ce qu'il y a des manques
est-ce qu'il y a des erreurs est-ce
qu'il y a des choses que vous avez voté
par compromis mais que vous ne soutenez
pas vraiment il y a toujours des
compromis on a passé des compromis entre
nous au sein de la majorité sénatoriale
avec les républicains et puis ensuite on
a imprimé notre marque dans le texte un
texte qui est sénatorial puisque à la
base la proposition du gouvernement
était d'inspiration sénatoriale ça
correspondait à ce qu'on appelle
l'amendement Savary qui nous votions
depuis plusieurs années donc ça allait
dans le bon sens à nos yeux et puis
ensuite on a imprimé notre marque
puisque les choix que nous avons fait
ont été votés dans le texte parce que je
vous rappelle qu'à l'Assemblée nationale
ils n'ont quasiment rien voté c'est nous
qui avons voté l'ensemble des articles
et donc qui avons imprimé notre marque
dans le texte donc vous dites c'est le
gouvernement qui s'est rallié à la
droite et au centre il y a eu des
compromis avec tout le monde personne
s'est rallié à quiconque on a travaillé
simplement
j'allais dire ensemble pour essayer
d'aboutir le meilleur texte il y a
toujours des frustrations il y a des
choses qu'on aurait aimé voir davantage
présent dans dans le texte sur la
situation des femmes nous souhaitions
aller plus loin
c'est pas suffisant on pouvait penser à
gagner un an par exemple pour le départ
des femmes simplement il faut faire des
choix parce qu'il est derrière ces choix
il y a des budgets et qu'il faut tenir
l'équilibre économique du dispositif
encore une fois s'il y a réforme c'est
parce qu'il y a déficit il faut aboutir
à résorber ce déficit si on arrive avec
un un résultat financier extrêmement
faible on n'aura pas j'allais dire
réussir notre mission où est-ce qu'il y
a pas suffisamment d'économies dans
cette réforme pour vous il va falloir
cadrer financièrement dans la dans la
CMP parce que il y a deux impératifs je
crois que la Commission mixparitaire qui
va se réunir mercredi elle doit vérifier
la pertinence si je puis dire budgétaire
du texte
encore une fois il faut qu'il résorbe à
l'horizon 2030 le déficit et en même
temps si je puis dire il faut que ils
permettent l'adoption du texte à
l'Assemblée au Sénat vous avez confiance
sur cette commission mixte la commission
mixparitaire j'ai je n'ai pas de doute
puisque nous sommes majoritaires donc
vous êtes majoritaire mais Bruno il dit
c'est pas gagné pour autant
quels sont vos lignes rouges vont pas
les lignes rouges ça va être le point
d'équilibre ça dépendra à ce que ce que
les uns ou les autres veulent mettre ou
retirer il y a des limites on peut il va
falloir faire des additions des plus des
moins savoir où on en est et le
gouvernement va nous dire ça ça coûte un
peu cher si vous voulez mettre ça voilà
je t'échange
on voit bien qu'il y a une pression sur
la situation des seniors pourtant était
une priorité au Sénat
notamment le CDI senior pour vous ça
c'est une ligne rouge ou ça peut faire
partie aussi des choses qui seront mises
dans la balance moi j'aime pas parler de
lignes rouges parce que tout dépend de
ce qu'il y a à la place quoi je veux
dire on voit bien que il y a des
demandes qui sont faites par l'Assemblée
nationale qui va vouloir essayer
d'un stylet si je puis dire dans la CMP
des propositions puisqu'ils n'ont pas eu
l'occasion de les discuter et quand le
texte va venir ils ne pourront pas
toucher au texte puisque les conclusions
du cm d'une CMP vous pouvez dire oui ou
non mais vous pouvez pas faire
d'amendement donc faut que ça soit
préparé dans le texte de la commission
mixte paritaire ensuite elle ira au
Sénat puis l'après-midi de jeudi à
l'Assemblée nationale et c'est là où on
vérifiera s'il y a une majorité ou pas
pour voter le texte donc tout doit être
prêt dans le menu si je puis dire que
que présentera la CMP mais notamment
dans cette CMP la question des carrières
longues qui risque d'être discuté
puisque là il y a des divergences au
sein même de la majorité
de la droite et du centre entre
l'Assemblée nationale et le Sénat est-ce
que ça pour vous ça fait ça peut faire
partie des points de crispation
oui bien sûr on l'a vu déjà quand le
texte était soumis à l'Assemblée
nationale c'est un problème interne
républicain il va falloir trouver
nationale non mais clairement le
gouvernement il a maintenant des heures
difficiles devant lui parce que il doit
s'assurer de sa majorité
dans sa majorité relative on sait très
bien que un certain nombre de députés
légitimement comme ailleurs ont des
états d'âme parce que aussi ils
regardent par la fenêtre voit leurs
électeurs qui défilent ils se demandent
si il est bien pertinent de voter le
texte c'est la vie et puis ensuite
vous pensez que le gouvernement ne fera
pas le plein des voix au sein de la
majorité entre Renaissance le modem et
horizon va y avoir des détections
peut-être après c'est le rôle du
gouvernement d'essayer de les convaincre
de voter mais on sait très bien qu'il y
a un certain nombre de députés je sais
pas ils peuvent être trois quatre huit
mais il y en a un certain nombre qui
s'interroge certains l'ont dit
publiquement bon après il faut
convaincre j'allais dire ceux qui
peuvent apporter un appoint c'est-à-dire
le groupe républicain et certains
membres du groupe liote d'apporter leur
voix
bon à quel prix mystère et boule de
gromme c'est le ça va être la mission de
la CMP mais qu'est-ce que vous dites aux
député les républicains qui ne sont pas
partis pour voter le texte
mais là encore c'est en conscience je
veux dire moi je n'appartiens pas aux
républicains j'ai pas de leçon à leur
donner mais je vais dire à partir du
moment où il y a une ligne politique
qu'on a partagé et qui consiste à dire
il y a une nécessité à voter le texte
bien sûr il faut le discuter il faut
l'améliorer il faut le négocier mais il
serait bon ton j'allais dire de le voter
mais je peux pas être la question est-ce
que vous seriez prêt en CMP à céder sur
la question des carrières longues
puisque c'est ça le point bloquant
c'est-à-dire c'est toujours pareil si
vous mettez de l'argent pour les
carrières longues qui sont quand même
pas l'alpha et l'oméga de la réforme ça
coûte cher et donc qu'est-ce qu'on prend
comme argent ailleurs
ou si c'est sur les CDI seniors ça va
être compliqué
avec la participation d'Olivier Marleix
le risque sont placer limité
votre fenêtre oui oui j'imagine que
Olivier Marleix a tenu à être présent
pour pouvoir j'allais dire peser sur les
débats et essayer de trouver les points
d'équilibre bon on le saura dans les
heures qui viennent sur le 49-3 fabrique
sur le 49-3 oui est-ce que pour vous
c'est il y a pas un danger à utiliser
49-3 infini d'autant que ce matin
j'entendais votre ami centriste Charles
de Courson à l'assemblée qui ne dit pas
non
une hypothétique motion de censure
transpartisane avec le rassemblement
national
ouais tellement de choses par les temps
qui courent
il faut 289 voix
bon les abats pour l'instant je vois pas
une motion de censure on peut toujours
faire des moulinets en disant
retenez moi où on fait un malheur bon
peut-être toujours est-il que il faut
289 voix et pour l'instant je les vois
pas
ce qui est sûr c'est pas une alliance
entre le rassemblement national la nuque
et une partie des républicains et le
complot dont vous parliez ça ne peut pas
arriver ça ne peut pas arriver pour vous
faut jamais dire jamais surtout en
politique bon mais je ne le vois pas
aujourd'hui je ne le discerne pas dans
les positions des uns et des autres donc
49-3 c'est comme reste c'est dans la
Constitution il y a eu un nombre
invraisemblable de foi ou 49,3 a été
utilisé bon c'est une arme
constitutionnelle à partir de là c'est
politiquement pas très heureux de
l'utiliser mais si le gouvernement n'a
pas d'autre choix
je pense qu'il pourra l'utiliser
maintenant il faut tout faire pour ne
pas avoir à l'utiliser parce que
politiquement effectivement c'est pas
très heureux de
j'allais dire d'imposer cette réforme et
socialement est-ce que ça ne
déclencherait pas ça ne radicaliserait
pas le mouvement social
moi j'observe que le mouvement social il
s'est exprimé je veux saluer le le rôle
la responsabilité dont on fait montre
les syndicats en particulier la CFDT ont
derrière tout ça on en a un peu parlé
mais il y a la succession de Monsieur
Martinez à la CGT qui n'est pas pour
rien dans tout ce qu'on a vécu
ces dernières semaines dans les bagarres
internes pour montrer ses muscles pour
préparer la succession entre le syndicat
des transports et de l'énergie et puis
de l'autre côté
j'allais dire le courant de Monsieur
Martinez bon
je vois que le mouvement s'essouffle
malgré oui on l'a vu samedi
mais en tous les cas on voit qu'il y a
un certain essoufflement quand même dans
la revendication et c'est la raison pour
laquelle mais je l'avais déjà dit à
votre micro je pense qu'il est important
derrière cette réforme faire une
conférence sociale parce qu'on a des
textes un peu épars
réforme des retraites indemnisations du
chômage un texte travail au mois de mai
des expérimentations par Monsieur Attal
sur la semaine de quatre jours la valeur
partagée etc etc vous demandez toujours
cette grande entreprise sociale qui est
on parle tout à l'heure de division
assez rapidement il faut que le
Président de la République prenne des
initiatives il le fait pour les
institutions il pourrait le faire aussi
au plan social la refondation dont on
nous rebattait les oreilles on sait pas
trop ce que c'est devenu il y a des
réunions clandestine ici ou là on sait
pas trop bien à quoi ça sert ferait
mieux d'avoir une vraie discussion
j'allais dire avec les syndicats les
représentants du patronat
les élus territoriaux pour la fonction
publique pour dire et maintenant il y a
une société poscovide faut réfléchir à
tout ça travaillons-y vous venez de
saluer la responsabilité de Laurent
Berger de la CFDT en particulier
est-ce que vous pensez qu'il sort il va
sortir renforcé ou affaibli de ses bras
de fer avec le gouvernement
ah moi je pense qu'il est il est
renforcé il est renforcé de toute façon
lui aussi prépare sa succession donc je
pense que c'est aujourd'hui à gauche
c'est le seul leader social-démocrate
en tout cas les manifestations
s'essouffle on l'a vu on a vu samedi
mais elle se poursuit les coupures
d'électricité on a quelques cas en
région les poubelles qui s'annonçaient
dans plusieurs rues de France dans cette
de Paris quel message vous adressez à
celles et ceux ce matin qui maintiennent
une impression sur le gouvernement qui
ne veulent pas du changement de l'âge
légal le droit de grève et légitime là
là où il ne l'est plus c'est quand la
CGT s'approprie les moyens de déesse
pour couper l'électricité à des
parlementaires faire pression
individuellement si on commence dans un
pays à faire pression sur ceux qui sont
détenteurs demande à parlementaire
on va vers quelle société c'est à dire
que vous allez utiliser les informations
que vous avez à la sécu EDF
à la SNCF etc pour faire pression sur
les gens moi je veux saluer des
collègues Olivier sigolotti Laurent
Duplomb dans la Haute-Loire à qui on a
coupé l'électricité individuellement en
rompant
j'allais dire frauduleusement leur
contrat
que des gens refusent de de comment dire
enlever les poubelles c'est pas très
heureux mais bon ils exercent un droit
de grève après c'est à la mairie de
Paris de prendre ses responsabilités et
d'user du pouvoir de police du maire bon
et de trouver des solutions mais qu'on
coupe
l'électricité a telle ou tel pour faire
pression où on va vous êtes journaliste
vous parlez dans des micros tous les
jours alors on va faire pression devant
chez vous vous menacez menacez votre
famille pour dire si vous tenez pas
cette ligne vous allez voir ce que vous
allez voir et les enseignants vont faire
pression sur je ne sais qui à l'école
enfin
voilà on n'a pas le droit d'utiliser sa
responsabilité
pour pour peser comme ça sur ceux qui
doivent choisir qui doit y avoir une
réponse de leur part je pense que sur le
plan judiciaire
cette réforme des retraites et cette
bataille sur la réforme de la retraite
va avoir des conséquences sur les
sénatoriales à venir en septembre
écoutez je sais pas assez loin septembre
de perdre des sénateurs toujours c'est
pas une chance exacte je veux dire
d'abord il y en a qui ne se représente
plus
donc il y a des évolutions dans les
départements je crois pas qu'il y ait un
mélange des gens ça peut exister
personnellement en réponse à votre
question je crois pas
et d'autant que encore une fois c'est
très loin septembre souvenez-vous il y a
trois mois ce qui se passait
pas surtout le monde s'en foutu
[Musique]
et à la présidence du groupe toujours
si j'étais un il faudrait que je sois
candidate deux choix élus trois que mes
collègues
acceptent de me dire
pour l'instant on a du travail donc la
question se pose pas on verra ça plus
tard vous parlez de la réforme des
institutions on va terminer là-dessus
Emmanuel Macron reçoit cet après-midi
les associations d'élus pas
l'Association des maires de France
puisque David Lisnard est absent déjà
c'est un problème qui est pas
l'Association des maires de France et
Lisa a refusé que tu avais dit snares se
fasse représenter
aurait pu accepter qu'il soit qu'il soit
représenté et je pense que c'est un acte
politique elle est évidente il y a une
forme de défiance à dire Geneviève pas
bon est-ce que parce que cet après-midi
est-ce que vous êtes favorable à un
redécoupage des régions à nouveau
écoutez je crois que on a déjà beaucoup
j'ai habité
le périmètre des régions Monsieur
Hollande a fait ça sur un coin de table
à l'époque je me souviens encore des
titres on va gagner 50 milliards en
redécoupant les régions je pense que ça
a coûté au moins 50 milliards donc on
les a pas gagnés mais est-ce que il y a
pas une opportunité à revoir
éventuellement cette copie en tous les
cas ça se discute on voit bien que dans
le grand test il y a un souci entre
la Région Alsace et puis le reste de la
région on voit bien que l'Occitanie est
une énorme région il y a même pas
découper ou pas Carole Delga la
présidente de la région Occitanie est
président de la région de France elle
veut pas de redécoupage il faut d'abord
il faut faire des études d'impact voir
un peu la Cour des comptes a commencé à
travailler le sujet il faut travailler à
partir de des études d'impact pour
vérifier ce qui était bon ou pas bon
là-dedans et puis avant de relancer
des volontés de de couper les périmètres
il faut il faut voir le dialogue parce
que on change pas comme ça des régions
du jour au lendemain on suivra tout ça
on en parlera avec vous merci beaucoup
Hervé Marseille d'avoir été notre invité
merci Fabrice et on continue évidemment
à parler de la réforme de retraite tout
de suite dans le club